what do we got here
classic first person perspective body
and then
you have
it kind of out
facing the world
and then you have all these ideas for
that show up
and all these ideas are bing bing bing
bing bing bing bing bing bing and all
those govern your existence
like a heads up display of a hologram
and so what's said is well
what if
actually this had nothing
in its heads up display
it was totally empty
like this
no name time location identity
information whatsoever but you were able
to access your ZIP code or whatever
social when you need it to but not that
those things identified you
soon you could feel what the nature is
of this empty space like the sky you
know basically like this open empty no
no identifiers
and then on Earth
you could feel all of those different
differentiators and identifiers when you
need them but you weren't identified
with them
and you see like this fish eye
perspective is also really important
because if you're living kind of on this
perspective
very zoomed in you're very zoomed in and
focused right it's very difficult to get
you to zoom out when you zoom out you
can focus more more on like the bigger
picture on the open space instead of
just on
the single object
so it's like that
and uh
this is like your name
and your personality and
all your attributes and identifiers and
features
and this is the featured list without
any identifiers or attributes the open
space that everything shares
foreign
[Applause]